you know I play CSU we just we just
played uh last last weekend or last
Saturday
you know just making sure my my guys
straight yeah you know just making sure
he good checking in with him I know we
we talked after the game on the phone
and then through the DMS and stuff and
they made this happen for the people
that love to see negativity they're
saying a negative video man it's great
positive and you know how we get I feel
like if that didn't happen we're gonna
be here right now so it's a blessing
that that happened so now we can we can
show people the other side of football
like football is just a game at the end
of the day and people we're the people
that play it so we're gonna get hurt
eventually you just can't look at it as
negative it's something that's good
coming out of it like right now this
video is something good that's coming
together something good that came out of
that injury or that football game so